Yes,
we're live.
Tommy bonds us do it,
dude.
Did you,
um,
did you go to the comedy store at all yesterday?
Yesterday?
No.
Going the night is heavy.
It wasn't heavy.
Yes.
Here.
Yeah.
I imagine it would be heavy.
The day after Mitzi died,
the clothes,
the comedy store down on Wednesday and yesterday was the first day it was open.
It was heavy.
I imagine that's the first time it's been closing alone.
Like they never closed.
I can't remember the last time it was closed.
It was heavy.
You could just feel it in the air.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I felt it was everybody talking about it,
but it was bombing to really
not on my show wasn't too bad when the Olr man,
uh,
it was thick.
Boy is in the air,
you know,
that's real sadness.
Oh yeah.
Pauline,
I've never seen Paul.
He cry.
He was there.
Yeah.
Paul,
he was crying in the onstage.
No,
he didn't go on stage.
She's not going to go on stage for a while.
I wouldn't have gone on stage if I wasn't getting ready for the special.
I would have definitely taken the night off.
Yeah.
If I could have,
you know,
if I wasn't earning for tweet,
people aren't,
are going to see it.
It just felt,
I didn't feel silly.
You know what I mean?
I like to feel silly.
I feel loose,
loose in a good mood,
happy.
Everybody felt vulnerable.
Everybody felt,
you know,
I mean,
out of all the people in the world that are not comedians,
she is under the number one most important figure in all of comedy.
Wasn't a comedian.
And then even when you say the ones that were comedians,
damn,
she's in the running for number one.
Even with the Comedians,
I know she's shaped so many,
you know,
she built that whole,
that place and,
and,
and she,
she,
you know,
they call her godmother,
but it really was like that because she advised so many people,
and actually here's the thing,
a lot of people have advice for you,
but yeah,
she was giving good advice to people.
I mean,
look how many people hire,
hold her in that regard.
Yeah.
You know,
legendary people are like,
she's it man.
Universally.
Yeah.
There's no one going Mitzi shore and shit.
No.
Nobody says that she didn't pass you.
Yeah,
like me.
I met her once and she was like,
no thanks.
What year was this?
2006 or seven.
Oh yeah,
I remember.
Well,
here's the thing,
when I met her,
she was,
um,
she was already like,
it was at the end of when she would be at the store.
She was,
she was not 100% doing well.
No,
she was rough around then when you would see her,
she would be shaking.
It would be very hard.
Yeah.
I just,
you know,
when someone's gone,
you stop and think about those times when you were around them and just like,
I wish I took it in and realize more that she wasn't,
she wasn't going to be there one day,
you know?
Did you guys have a good relationship?
Yeah,
we did.
I mean,
up until the seven years that I wasn't there and even then,
it was never her fault.
I called her the day that whole Mitzia thing broke out.
Like I called her up and told her everything.
I told her.
The guy's been stealing material and the whole deal,
and they'll,
every comedian feels so uncomfortable working around them that they flashed the
light whenever he's in the room so that no one does their material.
And you just start working the crowd.
I go,
it's a fucking war zone there.
It's terrible.
And her exact words.
Well,
wow.
Jazz Day away from mom.
What time you want to go up tonight knows it.
Yeah.
And I,
I said,
and whenever you want to put me up,
she gave me a spot.
And then the comedy store called me an hour,
two hours later or whatever it was and said,
I was band.
And I said,
I go,
what the fuck are you talking about?
I just got off the phone with Mitzi.
She gave me a 10 o'clock spot.
They're like,
well,
Muchi wasn't aware of everything that was happening.
I got the fuck she wasn't,
I told her,
I told her everything.
I go,
who's running the store?
No.
Uh,
you,
you run in this door.
The Fuck Outta here.
I'm not working for you and you guys are going to ban me because I outdid a joke
thief like this is you guys sell art.
You've got a thief of art that's in your midst.
Yeah,
you did.
You understand that.
What a big deal that is.
Someone is making millions of dollars off stealing other people's ideas and you
guys are just going to let it go because he sells tickets.
The Fuck Outta here.
But my Cora was never with her.
I was with the other guys.
Did you guys speak after that happened and I ever spoke to her again.
Wow.
I said,
yeah,
well by the time I came back she was real rough,
real rough.
You know she had other things to worry about.
Of course
he said,
well I had that one showcase.
Those.
My only direct experience with her when I met her in 1994 she gave me a lot of
good advice.
She did.
She,
she always gave me good spots like hard fucking spots.
Always like after dice,
after Martin Lawrence after anybody who would crush.
I go on after him,
after Chris Rock,
after this guy,
after that guy,
anybody that would crush she,
if she liked you,
she would give you the,
the death spots really well.
But she,
she realized that you have to,
you gotta eat shit man.
You got to develop.
You can't just have,
it's like there's an analogy with fighting.
Like you can't just fight people that you could beat the shit out of.
You have to fight people that are going to test you.
Sure.
Cause otherwise you're going to develop like a unrealistic sense of your
abilities and an unrealistic sense of other people's abilities.
And you have to,
you have to,
you have to feel what it's like.
I think as an up and comic comic,
like you start thinking you're pretty good.
And then you have to see someone who's really good and then you go,
oh my God,
I'm terrible.
And then you go on after them and that feeling of just total ineptitude or you
just feel so shitty and clunky and awful.